[MUSIC PLAYING]
MONICA WALSH: Hello,
and welcome back.
Welcome back to the second
part in our series on Unlocking
Creativity, Part
Two-- Talks at Google.
My name is Monica Walsh, again.
And I am on the Photos,
Streams, and Sharing Team here
at Google.
And it's my great
pleasure and honor
to welcome you back
to this series.
We're about to have
some of the most highly
acclaimed composers, musicians,
and producers on the stage
here at Google.
And I am screaming in my
skin about the sheer talent
and intellect that
we're about to see.
I was backstage, and listening
to them riff was remarkable.
So you're in for
a treat, everyone.
Before I let them
loose on stage,
I want to take some time to
introduce them and honor them
for their accomplishments.
So listen up.
Let's welcome back to the
stage Mr Kenny Warner.
[APPLAUSE]
Kenny performed last night at
the San Francisco Jazz Center.
And we all know him.
So welcome back, Kenny.
[APPLAUSE]
Our next guest is most famously
known for his time in a band
called The Cure.
You might have heard of them.
I danced my butt off
to them in college.
Roger grew up in East London,
born into a musical family,
and studied art and design.
He's felt a happy tension
between his love for art
and design and his
passion for music.
Now in his solo career, his
work bridges both worlds,
having released eight
albums, including his biggest
project which debuted in
London, called "Quieter Trees."
This is a suite
he wrote performed
for chamber orchestra based on
a painting by David Hockney.
In 2011, he was asked to rejoin
The Cure to take another tour.
Of course he said yes.
Some of his fans
from my generation
are really excited about that.
Roger continues to
pursue his solo career
alongside his work
with The Cure,
and proclaims to feel
the freest he has ever
felt in his entire career.
We'll hear more about
that on the panel.
Let's welcome to the
stage Mr Roger O'Donnell.
[APPLAUSE]
ROGER O'DONNELL: I don't
remember saying any of that.
MONICA WALSH: As I
was getting to know
this next artist,
Terrace Martin,
I noticed the way his
creative work was described--
very similar to a fine wine.
He just debuted his recent
album "Velvet Portraits"
at the San Francisco
Jazz Center last night.
Here is how his music has
been described-- "He never
stays in one place for too long,
yet maintains a breezy spirit."
He fuses jazz, G-rap, hip hop,
and is often the binding agent
in all of his projects.
Terrace Martin is a
multi-instrumentalist, two-time
Grammy Award-winning
music producer,
and is perhaps most well-known
for his producing records
of prominent artists like
Kendrick Lamar, Snoop
Dogg and Stevie
Wonder, to name a few.
He is a rare genius music
producer in Los Angeles.
And we are incredibly fortunate
to have him here today.
Please welcome to the
stage Mr Terrace Martin.
[APPLAUSE]
I told you.
Next, Mr Philip Glass is a
world-renowned composer-pianist
whose work spans generations.
There is no doubt
Philip Glass has
had a transforming presence in
our musical and intellectual
lives.
In the last 25
years alone, Glass
has composed more
than 20 operas,
eight symphonies,
two piano concertos,
soundtracks to films, and still
maintains his expansive solo
creations on both
piano and organ.
Philip grew up in Baltimore,
studied at Juilliard,
and moved to Europe, where he
trained with Nadia Boulanger
and worked closely with
the composer Ravi Shankar.
Philip Glass is best known
for his repetitive structures
in music, and has developed
what some call minimalist music.
When he returned to New
York in the late 60s,
he formed the Philip
Glass Ensemble,
and still performs with
that group to date.
This November, Philip
Glass turns 80,
and he's still going strong.
He has collaborated with Paul
Simon, Yo Yo Ma, to name a few.
And he still presents lectures
and performs solo keyboard
concerts around the world.
In 2011, he founded the
Philip Glass Center-- home
for artists, scientists,
and conservatists
to collaborate and produce a
culture of our renewal time.
Please welcome to the
stage Mr Philip Glass.
[APPLAUSE]
And the master conductor
of this evening
is going to be Mike Hawley.
And I'm going to tell you
a little bit about him
before he takes the stage.
So he'll be weaving our
conversation together.
Mike Hawley is the founder
of the EG Conference.
His background is well
suited for the role
today of conductor or
facilitator of our discussion.
He's an artist,
educator, researcher,
and previously a
professor at MIT.
He's co-founded several
groundbreaking research
programs, including Things That
Think and Toys For Tomorrow.
He was born in a
suburb of New York,
studied music and
computer science at Yale,
and did his doctoral
work at MIT.
Mike Hawley is himself
an accomplished pianist
and organist, having won the
prestigious first prize in 2002
at the Van Cliburn
Foundation International
Amateur Competition.
Maestro, I'll pass
the baton to you.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Can we pull
our chairs a little more
so we can see each other?
Because if I'm supposed
to be the referee,
I need to know who
to throw the flag at.
It's too bad you had to
bring a piano in for today.
I mean, it's too bad
because there should kind of
be a piano here always.
Why does it matter?
I don't mean to just
drop another budget
item in somebody's bill.
But when I was starting
NeXT with Steve Jobs,
we had a piano.
We had a Bosendorfer piano in
the middle of the software lab.
And meetings were sort
of like jam sessions
around an oddly shaped table.
And who knew that Bud Tribble,
who ran our software group,
could play every show
tune in the fake book?
There was always music
bubbling in the lab.
And I'm just sort of curious,
before we dive into our panel,
how many of you play music?
How many of you?
That's pretty good.
Keep your hands up.
How many of you have a piano
at home and should play it
but don't?
How many of you grew up
in a home with a piano?
About half, maybe.
I was always struck by the
fact that in the 19th century,
the piano was sort
of the internet.
Every home had a piano.
And the software that you used--
you'd go out to the local shop
and buy the latest whatever
by Chopin or whomever,
and try it out on
your own instrument.
But it has interestingly
different characteristics
from our internet, it's obvious.
But still, it was sort of
the universal interface
to music starting in
the early 1800s, when
the ingredients of technology
of the time sort of converged.
You had to have a cast-iron
industry to make a frame,
and that made a piano
loud enough, and so forth.
But every home had a piano, the
same way that every home now
has a computer and a portal out.
It was a social connector-- a
very important and interesting
instrument.
And that's sort of
where I wanted to begin.
I want to know where
you guys all started.
Did you all grow up
in musical homes?
Did you all grow up in
a house with a piano?
Were you playing music
from an early age?
PHILIP GLASS: Oh, yeah.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Keyboards, or--
PHILIP GLASS: Well I
started with a flute.
And we were only--
MICHAEL HAWLEY:
Started with a flute.
PHILIP GLASS: We
were only allowed
to do one instrument at
the time in my family.
So I picked the flute and
my brother played the piano.
But I wanted to play the piano.
So what I would do, I
would-- in those days,
the teacher would
come to your home
and give a half-hour lesson,
probably for $5 in those days.
It's quite a while ago.
But so what I would do, when
my brother was taking his piano
lessons, I would sit
in the room and listen.
And as soon as the
teacher left, I'd
run over and play the lesson.
My brother would chase
me around the house,
because he thought
I was stealing
his lesson, which I was.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Something
all composers learn young.
PHILIP GLASS: So later
on, I've reminded him
about this many times-- that
I ended up being a pianist,
and partly due to, probably
due to my brother, actually.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: And
Terrace, do you--
do you prefer Terrace or Terry?
We didn't get
properly acquainted.
TERRACE MARTIN: Terrace is fine.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Terrace, OK.
TERRACE MARTIN: But for you,
with all these wonderful
geniuses onstage, y'all can
call me whatever y'all choose
to call me.
It's OK.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: So
you play saxophone.
But how did you grow up?
What was it, a
musical household?
TERRACE MARTIN: Yeah.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Did you have
keyboards around, drums?
TERRACE MARTIN: My father is
jazz musician, jazz drummer.
And my mother is a jazz
pianist and jazz vocalist.
So I grew up in a strong
jazz household of soul music.
But my first instrument wasn't
the piano or the [INAUDIBLE].
My first instrument was
something called the MPC 3000,
which is the drum machine.
But it was.
This was my first instrument.
Because I grew up in
the 80s, the late 80s,
where a lot of households,
we didn't-- where I come,
we didn't have pianos.
And the music that was
being played in that time
was all hip hop.
So instead of all the younger
musicians maybe in the 50s
and 60s wanted to play pianos
and saxophones and everything,
now because of hip
hop, the whole culture
shift where now younger
musicians want to say, oh,
how do you do that?
That's called a drum machine.
So then the drum
machine replaced-- not
replaced-- but the
drum machine added
on like a whole other
extension of another instrument
to a whole generation.
And I come from that
generation, where
the drum machine and sampling
the records that everybody was
a part of, just to get
some type of information,
was all we had to do.
So those are my
first instruments.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: When did
you take up the saxophone?
TERRACE MARTIN: I
took up the saxophone
in ninth grade, after I
got into a young ruffle
with the law in ninth
grade, eighth grade I think.
And one of my neighbors
in the neighborhood
was a famous jazz drummer
named Billy Higgins.
And he was a huge mentor of mine
and for the whole community.
Billy Higgins said, when
I got out of my ruffle
with the law at a
young age, he said,
I'm going to take you
to go talk to my friend.
And he'll understand what
you're going through.
And his friend happened to be
this wonderful alto saxophonist
by the name of Jackie McLean.
And Jackie McClean
said, you have
a lot of time on your hand.
You need to do something
more than the drum machine.
I said, what should I do?
He said here, and he
gave me the saxophone.
And that's how the
saxophone came into my life.
MICHAEL HAWLEY:
And Roger, I know
you started young on the piano.
Was it there before you were?
ROGER O'DONNELL: Yes.
I grew up in East London in
kind of post-Victorian times,
most homes had a piano.
It was where everybody
would congregate
to entertain everybody else.
There's no television and radio.
But I was born a little
after that period.
So I was born, actually,
at home next to the piano.
So from the minute I could
stand, I would play it.
And as we spoke
about earlier, my mom
would-- our next-door
neighbor, she
would when my mom had reached
the dining room, because she
would hear the piano
start playing when
she was cleaning the house.
So I would sit underneath
and push the keys up.
And then I was big
enough, I would sit on top
and push the keys down.
And then my brother taught
me to play 12-bar blues.
And then I had piano lessons.
So it was always there.
It was always in the house.
And a lot of houses in that kind
of era of London had pianos.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Sure.
ROGER O'DONNELL: It wasn't
like an expensive thing.
It sounded terrible.
It was completely out of tune.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: And Kenny,
were your parents musical or--
KENNY WARNER: My father
was very musical,
but he didn't have the
luxury of training.
He had to support his
family-- step-father
and mother and children.
Then he had to support us.
But he had perfect pitch.
He played alto saxophone by ear.
And we used to play together.
And I know that whatever
I got came from him.
But we didn't have a piano.
Down the street,
one of my friends
was having a birthday
party, and his father
sat down and played piano.
And I'd never seen one.
I mean, I used to watch
on television Victor Borge
and Liberace, because they
were on TV, and Jimmy Durante--
who, by the way, way
before the Cream--
was it the Cream that break
all their instruments on stage?
ROGER O'DONNELL: Jimmy
probably started.
KENNY WARNER: Yeah,
but way before that,
Jimmy Durante would get so
frustrated with the piano
he would literally break
it till it was just
sitting on the floor.
And these are the guys I
watched, and Chico Marx.
Well there's a
great piano player.
ROGER O'DONNELL: I
love the Marx Brothers.
KENNY WARNER: But after I
saw it live, I went home
and I said, get me a piano.
MICHAEL HAWLEY:
How old were you?
KENNY WARNER: Seven.
And one of things
I said in my book
is I went and I found I could
plunk out any song I knew.
And I ran into the kitchen,
and I said, hey, mom good news.
I don't need piano lessons.
I just figured out how to play.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: So
they got you a piano?
KENNY WARNER: Yeah, they did.
They got a Wurlitzer--
a rent with an option
to buy should I take to it.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: OK, where
were you in the birth order?
Did you have your older
brothers, younger siblings or--
KENNY WARNER: I had two
very older brothers.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Wow, they still
paid enough attention to you
to get you a piano.
KENNY WARNER: Well, my brothers
weren't very happy about it,
but yeah.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: OK,
so full disclosure--
when I was about five
years old, we got a piano.
It was the piano that my
mother had grown up playing.
And like any kid,
I was drawn to it.
Who could-- I mean, you
push the thing here.
It makes sound.
You pull your chin
up over the lid
and watch the things go up
and down as mom plays-- put
your hand on the strings.
Lie underneath it-- it
sounds completely different
when you're on the floor.
And I was sort of hooked.
But I immediately
started playing by ear,
picking out little
nursery tunes.
My mom thought I should have
lessons, maybe go to Juilliard.
My dad thought maybe he should
play sports or something.
And so I got piano lessons.
I had a total of four
lessons and my teacher quit.
On the fourth lesson, she made
my parents sit through it.
She said, now Michael,
since you obviously
didn't practice any of the
things I assigned to you,
why don't you play something
that you want to play?
And I said, OK.
And I had this crumbling
piece of sheet music
that I found in the
bench of our piano.
It was "The Marine Corps Hymn,"
from the Halls of Montezuma.
My dad was in the
Marine Corps, and so I
thought he'd appreciate this.
I put this thing on the desk.
And I started playing it with
chords and everything, which is
pretty good for five years old.
And the teacher
threw up her hands.
And she said, look, he's playing
in a completely different key
from what's written on the page.
Save your money.
Maybe he should take up
football or something.
I was out of there, like a cork
out of a champagne bottle--
just no [INAUDIBLE].
And I played piano myself
through high school,
got an incredible
teacher in high school,
and took off like a rocket,
and came within a whisker,
I would say, of embarking
on a professional career.
I didn't go to
Curtis, but I almost
did, and then sort
of veered off.
But it's always been
a-- I mention this
only because you guys are
all professional musicians.
I'm an amateur musician.
And I often wonder
how my life would
have gone had I punched through,
and stuck it out at Curtis.
PHILIP GLASS: Well, I'm not sure
it means you are a music lover.
So we're all amateurs
from that point of view.
And I really
believe that's true.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: What would
you do if you weren't
making a living at music?
PHILIP GLASS: I'd probably have
a hard time making a living.
Actually, I didn't actually
make a living at music
until I was in my 40s.
So I did all kinds
of other stuff.
But I never took a
regular job, because I
was afraid of getting
trapped in the job.
I just did day work.
And I did that for a long time.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: But let's talk
a little bit-- just a little
bit-- about our lives
outside of music.
Because you surely
have hobbies and things
that you enjoy doing that--
PHILIP GLASS: I'm not so sure.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: I'm
guessing you might not.
But some of us do.
I often find things you do
outside of the day to day help
spark creativity in the sort
of mainstream of your life.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean, if you're a cook,
or if you're a camper--
PHILIP GLASS: I got
through collaborating
with other people-- with
dancers, with filmmakers.
I had the music
spark, but I always
thought, I work with people
who weren't musicians.
And then eventually, I began
working with other musicians
from-- people from Africa,
from China, from Australia,
from Mexico.
So the encounters
with other artists,
other performers-- that was
what was stimulating to me.
MICHAEL HAWLEY:
Now Roger, I know
you're heavily into Moog
synthesizers and things.
So you have to be a
part-time electronics hacker.
ROGER O'DONNELL: No,
I have other people
to fiddle with
those things for me.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: What do you
do when the stuff breaks?
ROGER O'DONNELL:
Get somebody fix it.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: You're not
writing code, software?
ROGER O'DONNELL: Oh, no, no, no.
That stuff gives me a headache.
I speak to-- I, obviously,
use a lot of software.
And I speak to those guys.
And they kind of say,
can you make it do this?
And they're like, yeah.
And then you're like,
wow, that's cool.
And also, instrument
manufacturers--
I'm very good friends with
the people at Moog and Cyril,
the main designer there.
And he knows things that I would
never know about electronics.
And when he says, I can make
it do this, I'm, like, really?
It's not anything I
would ever dream of.
All I can do is make music.
I can't make the instruments.
I can tell him what
I'd like it to do,
but the things that they
give us are amazing.
When Bob started-- and all
of those guys-- Dave Smith,
Tom Oberheim-- all of those
early guys, when they started
making synthesizers and
samplers-- what Terrace was
saying about sampling--
it just opened
a whole new world for all of
us, and allowed us to-- I mean,
you can't compare it to
any other kind of art.
If you think of a
painter being given
the kind of different tools
that we were given as musicians,
it just opens up a
whole new world to you.
When you sit at a
Moog synthesizer,
and you can create
the sounds, there's
no other instrument
you can do that with.
So you're creating the
colors that you can then
paint the music with.
So I don't know what to do.
I just know how
to twiddle knobs.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: But
it's interesting
what you say about painters.
I was talking to a friend
about the early Impressionists
like Monet.
We often forget what the
enabling technologies
were at the time.
His version of a synthesizer--
ROGER O'DONNELL:
Yeah, was paint.
MICHAEL HAWLEY:
--was paint in tubes.
That was a major breakthrough.
You didn't have to grind
the paint in your studio.
It meant you could take
a little box of paints,
go out, squirt it on a little
palette, paint in open air,
and capture the same
sort of impression
that an early
photographer might get.
ROGER O'DONNELL: Yeah,
OK, you having said that,
as Monica referenced earlier, I
am a huge fan of David Hockney.
And every time some new
technology comes along,
he embraces it.
And he takes his
art somewhere else.
So I guess they do have the
parallel with technology
that we've had.
But the huge
advances in keyboards
was amazing for me, from the
'70s through to the-- well,
it's still going on.
It's kind of micro.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: As
I said, Kenny, Roger
kind of grew up at the
perfect moment in history,
when all these little devices
and contraptions were evolving
by leaps and bounds.
How did you manage to avoid that
and stick with just a piano?
KENNY WARNER: Well, it
was very intimidating.
I didn't manage to avoid it.
I managed couldn't
manage to embrace it.
Of course, the piano is really
one of the first synthesizers
in music.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Sure.
KENNY WARNER: You've
got three strings.
That's signal.
And then when they put
the felt on-- before that,
it was like the harpsichord.
It was just wood on metal.
But when you put a felt
on there, that's a filter.
So I mean really, arguably, the
piano is the first synthesizer.
I got into it way later.
I mean, when I was in school, I
took the ARP-2600-- the course.
And I'm going, like, oh, my god,
this is like a science fiction
movie.
I wasn't thinking
that way at all.
I'm only a little
better at it now.
I, too, look for-- I get
sounds any way I can.
And then I like to stay on this
side of the creative side, what
the sound does to me.
I can't switch back and
forth to technical side.
It kind of kills what
am I going to write now.
It takes too much
of my-- that's me.
There's some people, like
Terrace, that thrive on that.
And I actually
really admire that.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: So, but
do you write or design
scores for multiple instruments?
Or is it almost entirely
improvisational for you?
KENNY WARNER: Well, I
compose on the computer,
because I'm left-handed.
And I have lousy handwriting.
And it was too much work.
Lefties, when they
would do copy work,
they used to have a
technique-- and you
might remember this-- they
used to use a six-inch ruler.
And they put nickels
on both sides,
so that the lefty could
rest his hand on the ruler.
Because every time you wrote,
you kept smudging everything.
And it was just
painful to me to write.
When the computer came, that
was just perfect for me.
Note, note value, note, quarter
note, note, eighth note, chord,
eighth note.
And then I went
hog wild with it.
And I wrote a lot of music.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Finale or
Sibelius or something else?
KENNY WARNER: It
started with Finale.
And then someone convinced
me to do Sibelius.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: That's for
the techies in the room.
KENNY WARNER: And then I
decided to go back to Finale.
Because it's funny
how your brain works.
With Finale, you choose
a note, and then you
choose a note value.
With Sibelius, you have
to choose the note value.
Then you choose the note.
Because otherwise,
it'll do the note value
of the previous note.
And I just could
not think that way.
It was [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Terrace,
do you write music down?
TERRACE MARTIN: I
write music down.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Using
the same sort of stuff?
TERRACE MARTIN: No.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Pen and paper?
TERRACE MARTIN:
Pencil and paper.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Pencil
and paper-- pencil
is probably a better strategy.
TERRACE MARTIN: Well, just--
and I've always wrote music.
I grew up in a strong
jazz, bring the chart
so we can rehearse things.
So I've been writing for years.
But just recently, I started
playing with Herbie Hancock.
And I was trying to tell
him-- not tell him anything.
I was suggesting to
him, look-- he said,
yeah, we're doing a new concert
and it's going to be me,
you, Vinnie Colaiuta.
I said, oh, cool, let's play
all these songs that I grew up
listening to you-- your songs.
But I have to remember as a
fan-- Herbie hasn't played
these songs since he
recorded these songs,
like a lot of these songs.
So this was the first time.
I always write charts, but
this was the first time
it was charts with pressure.
Because I have to
write his songs.
I have to transcribe his
songs, write them back.
So I remember the
first day of rehearsal,
going in a couple of weeks ago,
and I'm passing out the charts.
But I didn't give
Vinnie Colaiuta a chart.
And he said, hey,
where's my chart?
And I was, like, well, here.
It's just a chord.
I'll take it.
And I said, OK.
You know, with writing music,
and I wrote a lot of it
on the way there.
And I actually did
it two nights before.
So you kind of don't know.
I'm sure you guys know.
But me, I kind of
don't know exactly.
I have to make sure.
I have to hear what
they're going to play.
And with jazz, we
have to understand
all the rules to be able to
break the rules in that format.
So writing that chart
was the-- that's
when I realized
I made a mistake.
And Herbie said-- you know you
could get Finale and a program
to do this now.
So now I'm actually
going to get--
and this has reminded
me-- I have to get Finale.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: It's
interesting about Herbie--
we were e-mailing last
week about something else.
There was a young,
super-talented pianist
named Joey Alexander, who
I think has played here
at Google, if I'm not mistaken.
Any of you heard Joey Alexander?
Some hands?
He's like the Mozart of jazz.
Once a century, you get an--
TERRACE MARTIN: Awesome.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: --otherworldly
talent like this.
And I was talking with Joey
and his family saying, well,
have you thought
about going to school?
And the answer was,
well, yeah, but you
know Herbie dropped out.
And it's not my place to advise.
In order to drop out,
first you have to drop in.
And not only did he
drop in-- he dropped in
and he finished a degree
in electrical engineering.
TERRACE MARTIN: Oh, that's
right, electrical engineering.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: He was
interested in computers.
And lo and behold,
10 years later
when a sort of fusion
jazz movement gets going,
he's right in the thick of it.
Because he's interested in
these little things, and gizmos,
and gadgets, software, hardware.
He's got--
TERRACE MARTIN: And he
always thinks ahead.
He's not-- and this
is something I'm
sure nobody is-- he's
not in no particular box.
And I think that's the
big thing with creativity
is just to burn the box.
MICHAEL HAWLEY:
Philip in your world,
are you kind of a computer guy?
What are the ingredients,
the tools of your trade?
PHILIP GLASS: Pencil and paper.
MICHAEL HAWLEY:
Pencil and paper.
PHILIP GLASS: Actually, what
happened, the big crisis for me
was when the people
stopped making music paper.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: They stopped?
PHILIP GLASS: Yes.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: So you
had to get a computer
to print your own music paper?
PHILIP GLASS: No, I just
found a printer, found someone
to do it for me.
But for years, I
mean, there were
three or four different
places in New York
where I could go buy paper with
tints, and different sizes.
And it was part of the fun,
was going and buying the paper.
And they all went
out of business.
Then for a while, there was
a company called Judy Green.
I don't know who-- I don't
think Judy Green really existed.
But it was a company
in LA, and they
would send it to you overnight.
But then she disappeared,
or that disappeared.
And then I thought,
well, maybe I
can find-- I would just find
the printer or something.
And then someone who worked
with me said, no, no.
We'll just get someone.
Just tell me what you want.
And I could get paper
made for me, custom made.
Didn't cost any more
than the other paper did.
But I have all kinds.
And it helps for me,
believe it or not,
it helps to have
the right paper.
I mean, everybody has
their own little--
and I have to have
the right pencil, too.
You know that kind of thing.
I don't know how that
translates into computers,
but I have to have--
my tools are--
I'm very familiar with them.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: So if we were
to walk into your studio,
aside from the paper, and
pencils, and presumably
a pencil sharpener,
what else is there?
Is there a keyboard?
PHILIP GLASS: A big piano.
MICHAEL HAWLEY:
You've got a piano.
PHILIP GLASS: Yeah, sure.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: You
compose at the keyboard?
A little bit, or
you work out ideas?
PHILIP GLASS:
Especially some things--
with piano music for sure.
But the big pieces like
the operas and symphony,
you can't really
play it on the piano.
You can play parts of it.
So what you can do, you
can play part of it.
And you have to
imagine the other part.
I don't work--
then, in my studio,
I have-- that's
what I have at home.
I have an office
downtown, where there
are some young fellows
there who take the music,
and they put it
in their computer.
And then we can
make changes, and we
can make corrections,
and all kinds of things.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Print out parts.
PHILIP GLASS: All
that has to happen.
All the music preparation
has to happen.
But in fact-- now, here's
an interesting thing.
When someone will
call and say, I'm
playing this piece of yours,
and look at this measure,
and so forth.
And is this an E or an F?
And I say, I have no idea.
And they say, well,
didn't you write it?
And I said, are you sure?
But I've written so much music,
I obviously don't remember it.
But what I do know-- I learned
to do this a long time ago--
I save the manuscript.
I save the first sketch.
And I've learned to do this.
I write on the page,
Page 3, Page 4,
and the name of the piece, too.
So I can find-- so when I have
to find out is it an E or an F,
I go and take a look.
Because I don't remember
most of the time.
And it could be, very often
it could be either one.
You know how that can
be, or maybe an F sharp.
But that's about it.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: But you have
to be practical about it.
PHILIP GLASS: Well
I found out-- so
what we have in my
studio, which so I
have other people
doing the preparation
and doing the computer stuff.
But what we have is that the
MS means the manuscript--
the MS is always right.
No, it's not only right.
But it's pretty
much always right.
In other words, if I have
to go back to a piece of two
or three years ago, and
look at some measure
that I had forgotten
I'd even written--
MICHAEL HAWLEY:
All bets are off.
PHILIP GLASS: I'd
take a look at the MS.
And now, that doesn't mean
I always keep it that way.
I say maybe I should-- maybe
it is an E or something.
But the great thing is--
there's another good thing
about writing music
on music paper.
I have manuscripts of
everything I've written.
And most of my friends
just have files.
Now, that's OK, except you
can't sell the files to anybody.
ROGER O'DONNELL: I was going to
say, that's a good investment.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Autographs.
Kenny, what's in your studio?
KENNY WERNER: Well--
MICHAEL HAWLEY:
Your ideal studio?
KENNY WERNER: Computer,
big-- my ideal studio?
I don't even know.
Computer, large screen-- I
like manuscript on the screen.
So I had to wait for
the 32-inch screen
to be invented so that I
could see the whole score.
And a beautiful
piano, set of drums,
because I sometimes like to
come at it from the drums.
Netflix, so that I
don't have to just sit
there doing music all day.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: I
know it's important.
Roger what's in your--
ROGER O'DONNELL:
Well, I was just
going to say about
manuscript paper--
because in the rock
world, we don't use it.
And one thing that
our accountant always
claims for us every year
is for manuscript paper,
because he thinks it's
what musicians use.
So you say, what have you
claimed for us this year?
Well, I put down manuscript
paper and layout.
And we all look at him
and go, we don't even
know what it looks like.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: But you must
write on something-- backs
of envelopes, or?
ROGER O'DONNELL: No,
well, I play into logic.
I use logic.
I just play into it.
And I use the Vienna
Symphony Library of samples
for composing with.
And I just-- because I'm
not a trained musician,
I don't-- I need the inspiration
of hearing what I'm writing in.
So when I hear it back--
and the better it sounds,
that sample library
is so incredible
that it just inspires
you to add parts and put
other instruments in.
But my studio
revolves completely
around my Mac, and my
screen, and an input.
I've got a way to
keyboard a Kawai, that's
this virtual piano.
It's really good.
It's got the action
of a grand piano.
I have a piano in the house,
but I don't record with it.
I use Ivory-- the piano
sample, which is amazing.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Let's talk about
the extra-musical influences
and impacts, like dance,
and movies, and things.
Well, talk about your
discovery of dance.
ROGER O'DONNELL: Well, he
was talking earlier about--
Philip was saying
backstage that we don't
get to talk very often
to other musicians,
or we don't get to talk
to people from different--
because we're always
doing our own thing.
And actually, I find
more inspiration
from talking to other
disciplines, other artists,
visual artists,
dancers, writers,
than I do from
talking to musicians.
That may be the rock and the
not generally very inspiring
musicians.
But when you talk to any artist
that's passionate about what
they do, inspires me.
And most recently,
it's been in dance.
I saw my first ballet
four or five years ago.
And since then, I
can't write music
without thinking about dance.
And it's such a natural
combination to me,
that music makes people dance,
that it's a natural thing
to do when you write.
And Terrace does a lot
in the dance world.
So I'm sure he understands and
knows where I'm coming from.
It's just the feeling of having
somebody dance to something
that you've created.
I recently, just
before Christmas,
performed one scene
of an upcoming ballet
in Moscow, at the
Kremlin palace.
And we were in rehearsals in
the Bolshoi with the two--
MICHAEL HAWLEY: OK, wait, wait.
Stop right there.
I mean-- mind-blowing, to spend
so many years as a keyboard
player in a rock band.
ROGER O'DONNELL:
I've been very lucky.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: And
then just casually
write a ballet that's being
performed with the Bolshoi
at the Kremlin--
ROGER O'DONNELL: I don't know.
Obviously, I've been
very lucky to be
accepted into different
worlds that I go into.
And I think it's to
do with the passion
that you take with
you for your music.
And it's always interpretable
by other people with passion.
So back to the
rehearsal-- so we're
in the main rehearsal
room in the Bolshoi,
where incredible ballet
has been created.
And we were rehearsing.
I was playing piano
with four cellos.
And there were two dancers.
And we did a run through.
And then we stopped for a break.
And then I was rehearsing
a piece with the cellos.
They were all Russian.
They could speak English, and
they were all called Masha.
But I know how to count
to four in Russian now,
so it's quite useful.
So I said, let's just
go over this piece.
So we started to play it.
And the dancer, who's
also called Masha,
got up and started
dancing-- just naturally got
up and started dancing
to what we're doing.
And that was such an
incredible feeling to do that.
So that's the thing that
I love at the moment.
But it's about passion.
And when a young musician
comes up to me now,
and they ask for
advice, and we all
know how difficult
it is right now,
I tell them that if
they don't have passion
about what they're doing,
then they should probably
find something else.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Terrace,
have you tried things outside
of, say, jazz clubs and movies,
or other uses for music,
so to speak?
TERRACE MARTIN: Definitely.
Once again, for me being
a product of hip hop,
the whole culture-- hip hop is
one of the most accepting art
form of everything coming
into one, whether it's
rock, classical, jazz or
any-- we accept everybody.
We believe everybody
is one, definitely.
And also, through hip hop--
hip hop is not in music.
It is not a color.
It's just a thing.
It's a thing that we
all could be a part of.
And when you're a product
of such a strong culture
like that, you're involved.
And you're inspired by
the people around you.
Like my music, maybe in my
earlier years of playing music,
it was inspired by a
lot of other musicians--
John Coltrane, Pete Rock, Dr.
Dre, Lenny Kravitz, Snoop.
It was inspired by so
many different things.
But now, as I've gotten
older and I live life,
I'm really more inspired by
life more than music right now.
So I find joy into meeting
people, getting to know people,
shaking everybody's hand,
seeing what you're about,
what you're about.
What are you turned on by?
Especially children-- especially
children, because they
are the most honest.
If they don't like your
music, they're like this.
I just missed a
year writing this.
And you know what?
Children, especially
young ones, they
don't know terms like hip
hop, classical, jazz, rock,
anything.
They just know what makes them
dance and that feels good.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: That's right.
TERRACE MARTIN: So going back
to dance, and I said last night,
I believe the heart
is the first drum.
And I believe dance is
the first form of anything
that music can really
make you kind of move.
Everybody in here,
when you hear music,
the first impulse is to
dance, whether it's bobbing
your head or that situation.
And even when somebody walks
to me, I see dance in that.
You know what I'm saying?
That's why I'm inspired
by people living.
I'd rather play, instead of
how the bass line sounds,
I'd rather play how that
person is taking that picture,
sitting like that.
And I'd rather play the music
that-- I don't know if that
makes sense-- but feels.
You got me?
Is that a better shot of me?
But I'd rather play what is
the soundtrack to his life?
What's the soundtrack
of her life?
of your life?
That's more what I'm into.
So with me, as long as
I stay inspired by that,
I'll never run out of ideas.
Because I'm always inspired
by life instead of something
that's playing on the radio.
I'm so inspired by sitting
here, if I got his number,
I will call him 30 times
a day-- 30 times a day.
ROGER O'DONNELL: You're
not getting my number.
TERRACE MARTIN: 30 times a
day, because you do keyboards.
You know what I'm saying?
So that's just the whole--
ROGER O'DONNELL:
You know what you're
saying about when you
start, and you're listening,
you've got all of
these influences coming
through you, like when
you're talking about Herbie.
When I started
playing Fender Rhodes,
I learned every
one of his solos,
from "Headhunters,"
"Thrust," that whole period.
And it's that moment
when you become yourself,
when Philip said, when
he sits at the piano,
and it sounds like him,
that's a key moment of when
you-- everything that's gone
into you comes out as you.
And it's simple.
And that we pass that on.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: What
happens when you get stuck?
What do you do to get unstuck?
Or do you never get stuck
trying to work out a tune?
PHILIP GLASS: I don't
have time to get stuck.
I just keep going.
MICHAEL HAWLEY:
Too much pressure.
PHILIP GLASS: I just keep going.
Sometimes, I can throw
things away for a day.
I've thrown away enough stuff.
But it was stuff I had to
write down to throw it away,
if you know what I mean.
The thing that happens to
me-- I'm a little bit older
than some of you guys here-- but
the interesting thing happens
as part of the process
of aging, really, I
begin to hear differently.
I'm hearing differently
now than I did before.
That's changing the music.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Differently how?
PHILIP GLASS: I hear
different things.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Like--
PHILIP GLASS: Notes.
What do you want to call them?
I mean, I hear different music.
But for me, let's say that
dancing is about moving.
Painting is about seeing.
Poetry is about
actually speaking.
Music is about hearing.
Most of the time, I'm
listening to music.
I'm trying to figure out how
the hell to write it down.
The hardest part is
writing down what I hear.
Because you look, and say,
is that what I really heard?
Do you go through that?
KENNY WERNER: Well, when I
get stuck, I just walk away.
PHILIP GLASS: That's
probably more sensible.
KENNY WERNER: Well, I mean, a
lot of people would say that.
And then I come back,
and go, oh, of course,
I should do that.
Like next morning, it's--
have you ever had that?
You take a break, and come
back, and it's obvious
what to do next?
PHILIP GLASS: I have a
completely different problem.
And people who think
they know my music,
and I send them new piece.
And they say, well, there are
a lot of mistakes in the music.
I say I'm not sure.
And so we go over the score.
And it turns out they
say, that can't be a G.
And I say, please,
play the G. Play it.
And just the other
day, a friend of mine
was conducting a piece for
two pianos and an orchestra.
And he hadn't had
a rehearsal yet.
He said, it's too over-written.
It's too heavy.
I said, I know.
I'm hearing it that way.
I'm hearing very
thick music now.
He said, no, no,
no, it's too much.
So he called me the next day.
And he said, well,
I tried it your way.
It sounded better.
So he said-- and
he never had ever
admitted that he could-- before
that he would say that no, no,
no.
He knew what the right notes
were, and that I didn't.
But now he's starting to
say, well, you were right
and I wasn't that.
I was really amazed that
he-- but I'm hearing things
differently than I did.
And with luck, you'll
live long enough so
that will start to happen.
According to
neurologists, people
say the brain-- the brain
continues to evolve.
Maybe it's devolving.
I don't know.
But it's changing.
The structure of the brain--
we're still getting new ideas.
And what that translates into
is that you hear differently.
It's the damnedest thing.
You hear, you actually
hear differently.
ROGER O'DONNELL: The
thing that you said about
whether you can translate
what you hear in your head
to what comes out--
PHILIP GLASS: That's
the hardest part.
ROGER O'DONNELL: That's an
incredibly difficult thing.
PHILIP GLASS: Yeah.
ROGER O'DONNELL:
And that-- something
is this big when you
hear it in your head.
And it has to come
like this to get out so
that somebody else can hear it.
And when it's like
that, it's incredible.
When it gets to that,
let's hope it's still good,
but it's never as good as that.
KENNY WERNER: I do it
a little differently,
because I cannot for the life
of me plan out, hear something,
and say, oh, let me
try to capture that.
So what I do is, I
throw stuff out there.
And some people start writing.
And then they say, let
me see if I can create
the illusion of chaos.
So I start with chaos.
And then I keep
pulling things out
until it sounds like there's
a system that I might
have thought about all along.
PHILIP GLASS: You've got
it figured out real good.
KENNY WERNER: Oh, well it's
the only way I can do it.
Some would say you
have to tell a story.
First of all, you didn't
ask me what's my influence.
My biggest influence
is movies hands down.
Every chord has an emotion.
You know, you wanted
people to touch the piano.
You know, for example,
this is like--
and I've watched so many movies.
[PLAYING PIANO]
This is warmth.
This is nobility.
Now it's a little bit of doubt.
You know?
And now it's freedom.
But not for too long.
And so on and so forth.
When I'm thinking movies,
I can really play.
When I'm thinking piano,
I can't play at all.
PHILIP GLASS: This
is a man who's
made friends with the piano.
And I've never
been that friendly.
To me, it's always
been I have to work.
I still work at
playing the piano.
I'm still practicing.
KENNY WERNER:
That's the problem.
No, can I tell
you a funny story?
PHILIP GLASS: Please.
KENNY WERNER: Walter Norris
was a great piano player.
He passed away a years
ago with a heart attack.
And he was one of these guys,
these chronic practicers.
They practice all day,
got carpal tunnel.
PHILIP GLASS: I don't
practice all day.
KENNY WERNER: Well, so he
had his first heart attack.
And the doctor told
him-- we were friends--
and doc told him, you could
only practice 15 minutes a day.
So Walter lived in Berlin.
He e-mails me.
He goes, can you imagine?
The doctor told me I can only
practice 15 minutes a day.
I emailed him back,
you mean every day?
For me, I do it a
little different.
Everybody does it the way
that they have to do it.
There's a way in.
And of course you don't-- I
don't think anybody on this
stage is hampered by what's
in the way in, once they find
the way in for them.
PHILIP GLASS: I
think that's true.
KENNY WERNER: I think
that's the only way.
PHILIP GLASS: The method
becomes very personal.
And in a way, it becomes
impossible to really teach it
to someone.
They have to find their own way.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: A
couple of points
came up that just reminded me
of some of my early experience.
It has to do with
learning to hear music.
One of the typical exercises
that a kid will get in music
school is to harmonize a line.
You get a melody,
like a chorale melody,
and you got to write
three voices underneath.
And one of the first
things you struggle with
is trying to hear
all four voices
at one time in your head.
It is an unnatural act.
And there's a moment
at which you finally
do begin to get a sense of how
these different threads sound
inside, without even playing
them on the keyboard.
And then, of course, you
pick up an arrangement
that Bach of the same tune
and think, why didn't I
think of that?
I mean, look at
that miraculous--
that one idea-- you
know the feeling?
But it's sort of the
first big threshold
that I remember crossing
in learning music--
that you could begin to hear
these things without just
having to thump them
out on the keyboard.
That's why I'm fascinated
by your perspective now.
You say that music
sounds different.
And you're hearing
different things in it.
And I'll be parsing that
for a while, I guess.
Failures-- are there
any interesting failures
that spring to mind?
ROGER O'DONNELL: What, that
we're going to admit to?
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Yeah,
that's the whole point.
ROGER O'DONNELL: We're not
going to admit to any failures.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Forget
about the two million people
that are tuned in on YouTube.
ROGER O'DONNELL: We probably
fail nine times out of 10,
but they don't get
to hear it, do they?
MICHAEL HAWLEY: It's a
question of attitude.
ROGER O'DONNELL: Well,
what's failure, though?
MICHAEL HAWLEY: That's my--
KENNY WERNER: Yeah, you
have to define that first.
I have something I've been
telling my students just
lately.
In a way, it's
kind of irrelevant,
not to-- I've been
telling my students
it takes faith and trust.
You trust your hands.
And then whatever comes out, you
have the faith that it worked,
even if it didn't.
And then again, that's a
way of opening the channel.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: When
I was listening to you
play those beautiful
Bernstein tunes
with different
harmonies-- fun harmonies,
delicious harmonies--
I was thinking,
well, you know,
there's not really
any wrong notes in there.
And then I remembered,
Franz Liszt
used to tell his piano students,
there's no wrong notes.
They're uninvited guests.
And if they turn up, you try
to make them feel at home.
You improvise around it.
And that's--
KENNY WERNER: Or invited guests.
I mean, Miles Davis said,
don't fear mistakes.
There are none.
Everybody knows some
version of that.
But there's a funny
story about Herbie,
in the first chapter
of his book, talks
about the first chord he played.
He was so intimidated
playing with Miles
Davis it was totally wrong.
And then Miles took that chord,
and he created some new music.
But there's one
other funny story.
I heard Charlie
Parker was playing.
He would always play
with local rhythms--
Charlie Parker's a great
be-bop saxophone player.
He would always play with
local rhythm sections.
That's what they did.
That was in
Cincinnati, wherever.
And this piano player had
to pick him up every day.
And Charlie Parker never
said a word to him.
He'd pick him up.
Charlie got in a car.
They got out.
Charlie took his horn.
They played the whole
night, got back in the car,
never said a word to him.
And one night, this piano
player played completely
the wrong chord.
And Charlie goes,
mm, I hear you.
He said, I hear you.
That was the only thing
he said to him all week.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: How about kind
of big flashes of inspiration?
Do those ever happen, where
suddenly something goes off,
and it's like the
floodgates are open?
And you're off to the races.
PHILIP GLASS: I call
those lucky days.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Lucky days?
PHILIP GLASS: They come
now and then, occasionally.
Occasionally.
And it's wonderful when it
happens, because that means,
well, I guess that happened
to Schubert and Mozart
all the time.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: I don't know.
I think there's--
PHILIP GLASS: It can happen
even to ordinary people like us.
And then it does.
It's a beautiful thing.
I've written one
whole piece that
was like writing a
letter to someone.
I never-- didn't change
a note, the whole opera.
And I thought, wow,
that was a freebie.
But getting about--
there's another thing
that talking about
failures, which
is an interesting question.
If your music over time
changes-- and often it
eventually it does for
most people after a while--
then you find that
you've written a piece
that surprises you.
And my first instinct
is that maybe I'd
better not show it to anyone.
And then I say, no,
I'll just play it.
I'll give it to the orchestra
and they'll play it.
And we'll see what happens.
And no one has that
response except me.
I'm the one that's most puzzled
and alarmed by something that
is radically different from
what I did before-- completely
alarmed by it.
And I've learned to just
shut up, hand the music out,
and listen to it.
There seems to be another
entity operating in some ways,
where these things can happen.
And the big changes
in my music have often
been perceived to me as
failures, which I later
came to find out that
I actually had made
some fundamental change
in my thinking, which
I wasn't aware of until
I began to hear it back.
Does that ever--
KENNY WERNER: Absolutely.
ROGER O'DONNELL: I
think those moments
when you go back into the
studio and listen-- listen back
to what you wrote
the day before--
and you think, where
did this come from?
Who wrote this?
Those are amazing moments.
Of course, you look at
it, but I listen to it.
PHILIP GLASS: You ever say,
what jackass wrote [INAUDIBLE]?
ROGER O'DONNELL:
He's going nowhere.
Those are amazing moments.
And you just think those are
the moments you also think,
I can't do this again.
I'll stop now.
That's as good as it's
ever going to get.
PHILIP GLASS: I
have a lot of people
working with me in different
ways, copying these.
And you can't--
ROGER O'DONNELL: We all copy
you, Philip, by the way.
PHILIP GLASS: Tell me
I've written wrong notes.
And he said, no, this
is the wrong note.
No, this is the wrong note.
But that's been,
actually-- I've learned
to defend the wrong notes, and
because I know the right notes.
But the people I work
with, they're not
used to the wrong notes.
And I'm not used to them either,
but I know that they're right
even though they sound wrong.
It's a question
of I've just moved
into a different neighborhood.
It's exciting when that happens.
It's exciting to be
that close to failure,
if you see what I mean.
ROGER O'DONNELL: I think that's
when you are actually pushing
where you are going, isn't it.
If you're out of
your comfort zone
so much that you
think you're failing,
then you're actually
pushing your boundaries.
PHILIP GLASS: Yeah, it's hard.
If you're the one
on the boundary,
and you're pretty much
there by yourself,
especially all the people that
work with you are telling you
got it wrong.
But they're thinking
about a different piece.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: And I remember
reading one little thing
from Stravinsky, I think.
He'd get a commission.
Who was it?
Cole Porter was asked how he
got his inspirations for songs.
And he said, nothing
is more inspiring
than a phone call
from a producer.
That gets it started.
So Stravinsky would
get a commission
and start working away.
And he'd wind up with a stack
of paper that just didn't fit.
He'd have half of another piece
that for one reason didn't
work with what he was doing.
He wouldn't throw it away.
He just set it to one side.
PHILIP GLASS: We all wish we
had that piece he almost wrote.
MICHAEL HAWLEY:
You're so modest.
I mean, you said
something earlier about
how Schubert and
Mozart were different.
They're not like us.
Why do you think they
were not like us?
PHILIP GLASS: Well, I've
said this to people--
you're as likely to meet
Schubert or Mozart as to see
an angel walking on the street.
It does happen.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: I feel the
same way about Art Tatum.
PHILIP GLASS: What?
MICHAEL HAWLEY: I feel the
same way about Art Tatum.
I listen to Tatum
recordings of jazz piano.
PHILIP GLASS: They exist,
and they happen in a way--
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Game over.
PHILIP GLASS: They're
frightening and inspiring.
But if someone thinks
that-- maybe someone thinks
that's you.
Then, but you don't
think it's you.
It's hard for us to accept,
sometimes, that kind of--
KENNY WERNER: I think people
would probably think it's you.
PHILIP GLASS: What?
KENNY WERNER: With
your career, I
think people would
probably think it's you.
PHILIP GLASS: Well, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
For a long time, that got
me into trouble, actually.
I got booed off a lot of stages.
I don't know about you
guys, but-- [INAUDIBLE]
the orchestra, after the piece
was done, with the conductor
next to me, and the
audience was clapping
and the orchestra
was hissing me.
That's how-- some of
the best orchestras
in the country-- the
Philadelphia Orchestra,
the Cleveland Orchestra,
the Boston Orchestra.
KENNY WERNER: All right,
then I have a question.
After that kind of experience,
how do you keep going?
PHILIP GLASS: I felt great.
Because I wasn't there.
KENNY WERNER: So it didn't
throw you off your paddle.
PHILIP GLASS: No, no.
Those guys were stuck where
they were, and I wasn't.
KENNY WERNER: Yeah.
PHILIP GLASS: I actually
just laughed it off.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: We've got
about 15 or 20 minutes.
And I know there's
a lot of ideas
and questions in the audience
and a couple of microphones.
It would be impolite
of me not to say, hey,
if you want to step up and
ask a question, fire away.
Could you go to the
microphone here?
And I'm going to call on you,
because I can't really see.
Go, please.
AUDIENCE: So something
you all have said
reminded me of a
technique that I've
used when I get into a state
where I feel like my music is
all sounding the same.
I shut off the lights,
sit down at the piano
without being able to see the
keyboard, just play two notes.
And then from there,
try to work it
until you get to something
that's consonant.
And that takes away the
whole notion of what key
you're in and what
notes you're playing.
And you just hear the music.
And I wondered if you
all have tried anything
like that, or a few
other techniques
that you use to keep
yourself from sounding stale.
KENNY WERNER: Well, I find
that playing in one key
and then playing in the
other key very tonally kind
of satisfies me in
a kind of weird way.
I also just sometimes
just play with my entire--
from elbow to elbow,
but Christmas carols.
I just like doing that.
It's just kind of strange.
I wanted to do a whole record
of Christmas carols that way,
and my wife won't let me.
PHILIP GLASS: Let me
ask you a question.
It looked to me like
you were-- your eyes
were closed most of the time.
You weren't watching
your fingers.
KENNY WERNER: I
try not to watch.
PHILIP GLASS: You're basically
listening all the time.
KENNY WERNER: And imagining
someone else is doing it.
That really helps.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
This has been amazing.
Roger, you talked
about playing music
and it inspired
you to add stuff.
Kenny, you talked about
starting with chaos
and taking parts out.
Terrace, especially as a
producer with other artists,
do you ever-- is it hard
to know when it's done?
When the piece or
the record is OK?
It's done?
TERRACE MARTIN: They always
have to tell me to stop.
They always have
to tell me to stop.
For me, everybody feeds off
different energy how they work.
Everybody is inspired
by different things.
And usually with the
records I produce,
there's always this
quiet deadline.
This quiet deadline-- and I call
them where they're rushing you,
but they never give
you a date when
you have to turn take a
record into mastering.
So say, for instance, when I
produced the Kendrick Lamar
album, we had years.
We had three or four
years-- three years
to produce that record.
And I've produced
a lot of records.
But we didn't really click
until the last four months,
when they said, we're going
to master on January 3rd.
And then for some
reason, that fueled me.
And then, instead of adding
more things to the music,
I stop myself.
I listen to it.
I usually go back in the
studio, and I listen back.
And I say whoa, I need to
start subtracting things
instead of adding things.
And then usually I have
somebody next to me
that knows nothing
about harmony, nothing
about all my keyboards,
and they just
know how it makes them feel.
And I always say I trust
those people really
a lot more than musicians when
it comes to creative things.
And usually I have a crew
of people that I look at.
They don't even know--
they probably know now,
don't even know I look at
them on the side of me going.
In hip hop, they
say it's too jazzy.
That doesn't mean it's too good.
It means it's too much going on.
The conversation's different.
It's too jazzy.
OK, take out some instruments.
It's too-- like I'll
do an R and B song,
and put amazing Prince-style
distortion guitar.
They'll say it's
too Guns 'N' Roses.
And I'll say, OK, that
means turn down the--
so it's a few mechanisms
that I do use when to stop,
when I'm working on
other artist's records.
On my records, I don't
care what nobody says.
I go all the way in.
If it's the last song of
a ballad, three seconds.
And if I want to
get a orchestra,
if that was my heart tells
me to do, I'm going to do it.
But everybody doesn't
operate on that.
And as a producer, I do
have to be a professional,
and still open up and
listen to them as well.
MICHAEL HAWLEY:
So in other words,
it's kind of like a
big software release.
You've got the
release date, and you
can't be chucking more features
into the bin and [INAUDIBLE].
TERRACE MARTIN:
And I'm trying to.
I'm trying to add more songs.
You know, I hear more-- like,
he says something that all--
and that's just it my
spirit what you said.
Because I've been hearing
for the past, like,
I talked to Quincy Jones.
And he said, he's
hearing music the best
he's ever heard it right now.
Working with Herbie,
75 years old,
he said, he's
playing and hearing
the best music he's ever.
He said, he can't wait
to be 80 years old.
You know, it's like these
people-- it's like with the art
and being stuck-- I
believe if you're really
in love with this thing, you're
always going to want to grow.
And that urge to want to grow,
and accepting challenges,
and wanting to conquer
challenge kind of voids
out the failure
thing in a way, too.
Because it's like
it's a challenge.
Let's get through it.
I love-- going back to
the jazzy thing, when
Jimmy [? Ivine ?] and
everybody-- everybody
is not so into the jazz
thing, let me just say that.
So Kendrick said, I
want to do a record.
I want heavy jazz influence.
And Terrace-- oh, no, oh, no.
We're not going to people
dance, [INAUDIBLE] people this.
No, no, we can't.
It's going to be too
much music going on,
too much music going on.
But that kid had a vision.
And he followed his
heart with his heart.
And now it's the biggest
hip hop record right now,
because he followed his
heart, not because he followed
the train I was going on.
And we don't believe
in getting stuck.
When one person gets
stuck, we got to pull it
from the other person.
We've got to uplift each
other in our community
so we don't get stuck.
Those are very important
things, so that's my thing.
AUDIENCE: Very insightful.
Kind of a follow
up to that-- I have
a question more about
the business of music,
and how do you deal with the
commercialization aspects,
and outsiders trying
to influence your sound
and where you should
go with your music?
PHILIP GLASS: I didn't
understand that.
MICHAEL HAWLEY:
It was a question
about the business of music.
How do you deal
with the pressure
of the commercial market
relative to what you
think you should be writing?
Or do you not, ignore it?
PHILIP GLASS: I know when
I'm writing commercial music.
And I know when I'm
writing concert music.
I know, and the people who ask
me to do it, they know it, too.
If I'm writing a commercial
for IBM, that's one thing.
If I'm writing a
symphony for [INAUDIBLE]
it's a different thing.
It's not a problem.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: That was easy.
ROGER O'DONNELL:
I'm lucky enough
to have a day job that pays
really well in the Cure, which
allows me to experiment
and do whatever I want,
without any regard
to commerciality
or, if anybody wants to hear it,
I'm in a very lucky position.
So I wouldn't want to be
dealing with that business
side of music now.
I mean, it's changed
in the last 20 years
for new musicians starting,
wanting to form bands,
trying to make money.
It's virtually impossible.
I've got no answers.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Yeah, well, it
is a kind of a moving target.
I mean, when guys
like Bach were around,
the commerce was done
around wealthy courts,
and by dukes or the church.
And so you were constrained
in different ways,
and tried to push
beyond those boundaries.
The 19th century, you had big
rooms and paying audiences.
It was sort of the Ringling
Brothers approach to promote.
20th century, you
get movie studios.
That became a new home for
a lot of musicians in a way,
with different constraints.
And now we're in the
sort of post-Napster era.
TERRACE MARTIN: I want
to add something to that.
When I was trying to be a
part of this music business,
I would try to do
what's going on now.
I'd try to-- because I was
easily influenced by people
saying, you need to do that.
Or you need to do that.
You need to do up-tempo.
You need to do that.
And I spent like seven years
chasing my tail just trying
to do what I felt I should--
what people was telling me
I should do.
And the minute I stopped
doing that, and just said,
look-- because every time I
did try to sound like something
else, it sounded horrible.
I had the wrong drum
selection, the wrong--
it just sounded horrible,
because I wasn't in my--
MICHAEL HAWLEY: It
didn't sound like you.
TERRACE MARTIN:
That's not my thing.
And I didn't know then.
Sometimes we get caught
up in the business
with making a living,
and doing that.
But when I realized,
man, if you just
stay true to what
you do and sit still,
I'm a living witness
that it works over time.
And I'm still working
out things, and learning,
and still try to push
forward every time.
AUDIENCE: So Terrace, you
talked about children,
and how they have sort
of an unfiltered view.
And we've all heard
so much music.
You guys especially have
heard so much music,
and written so much music.
How do you find a balance
between your expertise
and maintaining
that child's eye,
and finding a way to sort of
bring both at the same time?
Everybody.
ROGER O'DONNELL:
I think expertise
is, like we were talking
about the Creative Cloud
or whatever you want to call it.
Expertise is just a
language that allows
you to communicate your ideas.
If you have all this
music in your head,
and you don't have the
technique to perform it,
or to get it out, then
you're really stuck.
I think when technique
comes before creativity,
then you are in big
problems, anyway.
Because it's not
all about technique.
It's about creativity.
But you do need the
ability to get it out.
I mean, there was a
big movement in music,
like punk, where it
was all supposed to be
about not being able to play.
But you still had to
be able to communicate
what your musical ideas were.
And we've probably all got
different levels of technique.
But we're able to
communicate what we feel,
and what our emotions
are in music.
KENNY WERNER: You
know, a lot of people
have the opposite problem.
They're creative, but
they have no patience
for developing language.
And I see that a lot.
I had a friend, great
composer, Donald Erb.
He said, the bars are filled
with very talented people.
But that's kind of part of
what I wrote about, too.
When it's time to
play, it's time
to completely open
up to everything
we've been talking about.
But when it's time to practice,
I think the joy of practicing
is just concentrating on not
just practicing some technique,
but really owning something.
And one of the ways
people sabotage themselves
is they practice too much stuff.
They don't really own anything.
Just to own a little bit of
something, you start to say,
I can do it.
And that language
will free you up.
You just have to
know when to go.
Just for lack of
better words, you
have to know when to
go in your left brain,
and when to go in
your right brain.
And I hope that's
the right stuff.
Right brain is for
playing, they say.
Left brain is for
concentrating, practicing.
I always tell people if you're
practicing is inspiring,
you should be suspicious.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: A couple more.
AUDIENCE: It might be a little
bit of an oddball question,
but do you guys
ever dream music?
PHILIP GLASS: I do.
MICHAEL HAWLEY:
Do you ever dream
music, music in your dreams?
ROGER O'DONNELL: Yeah, well,
that's part of that big thing,
isn't it?
If you could get that out.
KENNY WERNER: That's a hard one.
TERRACE MARTIN: I used to
dream-- my dreams of music
was always me playing in
Carnegie Hall with Bud Powell.
But with Jordan's on.
You know what I'm saying?
But I don't dream in music.
But I've always-- I remember
playing in marching band
in 10th grade, walking
into the football field
before the football
players got there.
And I always imagined I
was playing at Carnegie.
A setting in like--
I remember when
somebody scored a touchdown.
And they said, oh.
And I would imagine them
saying, Terrace, Terrace.
He ought to know.
So those are the
dreams that I had.
And I still dream about
Carnegie Hall and Bud Powell.
PHILIP GLASS: Since
a couple days ago,
I saw a beautiful movie called
"Dreams" by Kurosawa, Japanese.
And it's about 12
little stories.
And he, in the very first
part, there's a house.
And some writing in Japanese.
A friend of mine was
there and told me about.
And it said, Kurosawa
on the house.
So that was telling
us that everything--
and then the subtitles
had a name for each piece.
But in Japanese, it said,
"And then I dreamed this.
And then I dreamed this.
And then I dreamed this."
So beautiful--
"Dreams" by Kurosawa.
You can Google it.
You can find it.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Who's next?
AUDIENCE: "Einstein
on the Beach"
has been a piece
of music that I've
been listening to on and off
for probably more than 20 years
now.
So thank you for that.
And every time I
listen to it, there's
something new that's
revealed to me.
And I'm wondering if
the folks on stage
can talk about,
maybe, pieces or tunes
that have withstood
the test of time,
and that are still fresh
and new even after they've
been in your life
for such a long time.
PHILIP GLASS: Whoa, so many.
It's gone quiet.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: He
wants to know tunes
that have stuck
with you forever,
the melodies that you--
KENNY WERNER: No,
I think he said
pieces you've listened to that
you keep finding new things in.
Is that what you're saying?
AUDIENCE: Right, sort of
like the layers of an onion.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Music that you
never tire of listening to.
KENNY WERNER: I kind of stopped.
I don't listen to
much music any more.
It's just-- you say,
I hear differently.
You also start to
think differently.
More and more, it becomes just
this very personal dialogue.
It's not music.
And I heard Herbie say
that too, at one point.
It's not really music anymore.
It's just these sounds
that are coming out of me.
And if I listen to a lot of
music, I confuse it with music.
That must sound incoherent, but
when I think of it as music,
I get trapped.
When I think of it as
this sounds that I just
have a tactile sensation, or
even essential relationship to,
I start to expand.
So it's not-- I don't listen
something over and over again.
I kind of like, first of all,
I kind of like the silence now,
and then see what
comes out from there.
ROGER O'DONNELL: I
recently reconnected
with some Stevie Wonder albums.
And I remember listening to
them at the time they came out,
thinking that was
just incredible.
And you listen to them now,
and they're just as fresh.
And the sounds involved, like
a lot of Moog programming
from those two guys,
Bob [INAUDIBLE]
and the other guy's name.
But anyway, and you just
go, that's what Stevie did.
And you just think wow.
And you've worked with him.
TERRACE MARTIN: Yeah,
that was strange.
Sitting up here is strange.
I can't believe I'm even here.
I'm [INAUDIBLE].
Stevie Wonder is one of,
for me, there's two records
that I always pull from.
Rather sometimes, spiritual
reasons or just sometimes
I just like writing to it.
It is the "Purple Rain"
soundtrack-- Prince--
and "A Love Supreme,"
John Coltrane.
And I pull different things.
Like when I listened to "A
Love Supreme" by John Coltrane,
I hear things different.
There's no words.
But I hear aggression.
I hear pain.
I hear love.
And I just hear something.
When I first heard
"A Love Supreme"
and really listened to
it, I was in 11th grade.
And I was on the bus stop.
And for some reason,
he started "Stolen"
and it was a broad--
I'd just start running.
And everybody thought,
why is he running?
I ran on.
The music was so intense.
And it fed me energy.
To this day, I use that same
energy although it was jazz.
But I use that same energy if I
was doing a rock record, a hip
hop record, or any.
It is just the spirit of that.
And then for other reasons, I
make pop artist Stevie Wonder
record, because I love the
clavinet and mini-Moog.
I love the mini-Moog.
I say I have a
collection of mini-Moogs.
I just picked up one
two days ago on eBay.
I love the mini-Moog.
And Stevie knew how to
make those mini-- you can't
play chords on the mini-Moog.
But he would do these layers
that we could do now, just
with an instrument called
the ocarina on the keyboard.
But he would do these layers.
And when I got a
chance to talk to him,
he was saying he was
trying to make them
sound like flutes and strings.
But he was using the mini-Moog.
You know what I'm saying?
Definition, just like
the alto sax one.
I just found out
recently the saxophone
was used to replace strings.
I took a course at
USC for two days.
And there was something
about instruments
were used to replace
other instruments.
And I think the mini-Moog
is very inspiring,
because you can just go
in different directions.
You can make drums out of
one instrument-- the bass
and everything out
of one instrument.
Stevie Wonder does that.
So that's what I pull
from, different things.
Are you about to play?
MICHAEL HAWLEY: I
have a couple of tunes
in mind, just little things.
Because I don't have
the obligations that you
all have of producing music.
I have the luxury of
absorbing and fiddling around
with it at home.
And there are
melodies that stick
with me over 100s of years.
[PLAYING PIANO]
That's an old Bach tune.
Who doesn't like a good
Rachmaninoff concerto?
KENNY WERNER: Love Rachmaninoff.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: Liszt came
up with nice tunes-- sort
of the guy who
would have been John
Williams in the 19th century.
John Williams.
Any of you know that one?
It's Indiana Jones,
Marion's theme,
which is closely related to--
[PLAYING PIANO]
Princess Leia.
And then there's--
[PLAYING PIANO]
I'm trying to remember the tune
from Mishima that you wrote,
Philip.
You wrote the score for Mishima.
PHILIP GLASS: Yeah.
MICHAEL HAWLEY: There's
this fantastic sort of--
[PLAYING PIANO]
Something like that.
It's not ringing any bells?
Wrong key?
PHILIP GLASS: Yeah, it does.
I never tried it on
the piano, though.
MICHAEL HAWLEY:
Yeah, that's right.
But what everybody
is saying, I think,
is that these little stories--
these musical stories--
they sort of stick with you.
And they change over time
the way we change over time.
You listen to a--
[PLAYING PIANO]
I get attracted to that
piece over and over
again every few years.
It feels different to me.
KENNY WERNER: I have
a couple of those.
I have a couple.
MICHAEL HAWLEY:
Yeah, what are yours?
KENNY WERNER: Well,
I love this one.
This always just takes me away.
And it's a little
bit improvised.
[PLAYING PIANO]
MICHAEL HAWLEY: There you go.
That's a nice way to hear it.